today's topic keemstar goes on to talk
about a 20 year old that he's currently
seeing and he's seeing a lot according
to his words um he
made it clear
within the first few minutes that this
is not a fan because i know a lot of
people say the power play the power
position the power manipulation which is
a huge thing onto its own when you're
older richer and more successful you
have this power and you have the ability
to control this person based on those
three things and he matches
all the criteria now even if you don't
match all the criteria keemstar is 39
he'll be 40 next year dating a 20 year
old
it has been scientifically proven i have
been told this time and time again that
the female mind because he's within the
female mind natural born female minds is
not fully developed until the age of 25
with males sometimes it's up to age 30.
so
obviously that's why they say you don't
get married in your 20s and like you'll
make life decisions in your 20s because
20s
you change so much mentally like you are
physic like physically your mind is
changing so much
you're you're figuring out right and
wrong you're figuring out all this stuff
but if you have a much older person
what are we watching
big youtuber apparently dating some new
girl she's 20
next subject
i don't care
she's 20
he could have been 65 i don't care i
don't care
what happened to the girl
oh my god if you tell me nothing
nothing
i don't care we're making the thing out
of the thing that's not a thing she's
she's a 20 year old they don't ever look
at their family she's 20
i don't care she knows and i don't ever
victim blame the 20 year old or under 25
year olds like they shut up they don't
know shut up shut up hey go tell the
[ __ ] in the hood who committing christ
at 20 that they don't know what they're
doing yo they come so sorry
charging 20 year olds giving the 25 to
life but they can't choose to [ __ ]
somebody twice their age right this is
oh no they get they can actually charge
someone as an adult as low as 14. rough
so so i don't care you know what let me
channel some of that i don't care energy
can i get that take it okay i don't care
miss i can go to the military and go
kill some taliban
i could get killed by the taliban
i could go out there and do no killing
i could just go over there and shoot the
sky take some poppy seeds have a good
time i could do that i could buy a house
i could take a hundred thousand dollars
in lowe's i can start becoming a doctor
i could disown my parents what did you
know that you could disown your parents
them [ __ ] ass
yes you can you could do a lot of things
when you're 20 but
you can't [ __ ] a 40 year old
what
why not
but you know
he has so much money and power people
like that [ __ ]
you can't fly to dubai get a rich [ __ ]
he'll fly you it's none of my business
y'all some grown-ass adults here's what
i'ma say if you want to have your way
okay i got you
i got you
you are no longer an adult you no longer
have to make any decisions you don't get
to choose anything you are going to be a
[ __ ] child until you're 25
because that's what you want to be
treated like apparently [ __ ]
ain't got the agency to make decisions
for themselves so we're going to come in
for them and be like you can't accept
this not recognizing that women
naturally want to go for men who are
older bigger stronger faster and make
more money hypergamy is a real part of
existence if it's not for you keep it
[ __ ] pushing i can't sit there and
talk to 18 year olds because it's
mind-numbingly stupid but not everyone's
looking for profound conversations some
ladies just want to be with a [ __ ]
who's got a [ __ ] together i know because
when i was 19 she wasn't checking for me
you wanna know why they weren't checking
for me gotta have an apartment ain't
nobody trying to come back to my mom's
basement sorry it is what it is once you
got your place once you're more
established women are far more open to
dating you and to going back to your
place it is what it is that's why women
traditionally date men who are older how
many times did you know girls in high
school who had boyfriends who were five
six years older and he was like it's my
favorite why
because he knows how to dick me down
good why because a [ __ ] got experience
i just don't get this world it's
everybody's aiming to be a victim in
every situation now you have no agency
apparently well like what about the
power you want to be a groupie [ __ ] be
a groupie you want to be a groupie bro
go [ __ ] a doe
i don't give i don't care
adele had a boyfriend who made
substantially less than him than her she
was [ __ ] him well she enjoyed it and
he enjoyed it
is that skepta
what i'd [ __ ] it down
current or previous
both
off really yeah okay
i don't care
i'm on i'm on the
current side on the skinny side
i don't care hello from the other side
you know listen but as long as i'm gonna
have a face adele's gonna have a place
to sit on all right i ain't mad at that
i ain't mad at that big or excuse me
either you're old girl enough to make
decisions in society or you're not and
if you're not then let's have a
discussion about everything but they
never do that they never talk about
student loans like that whether or not
they should be allowed to take those
loans they never talk about their
military like that they only talk about
it with sex because this weird society
has an obsession problem with sex has a
problem with it and it's like it's a
very like you go to europe they don't
have these conversations this is like a
north american weirdo we have a problem
with sex like i said before
she's 20.
the way you talking about it she's like
she's 15 or some [ __ ] like that
she 20
i don't give a [ __ ] yeah i don't give a
[ __ ] she's legal let's keep it pushing
there's no there's no conversation they
think this is cool they think it's a way
to something money power fame
um maybe they have issues of their own i
know mine was issues with my father and
not having a father figure that's a you
if you got daddy issues good for you
that's your problem don't project that
on to everyone everyone thinks because i
did it and i had a terrible time if you
do it no [ __ ] that's a you problem oh
no i know what that's a you problem no i
know what this is this is a no you're
not dealing with it but actually jumping
to another file there's so many
different levels of why a young person
would do this and
none of it's their fault because they're
learning and growing and
it's shame on the almost 40 year old for
for doing this for
for causing more trauma to this person's
life it's crazy how they have zero
culpability in this kind of situation
let them go rob a bank and you won't be
saying that stupid ass [ __ ] i don't care
how mature she is i don't care how young
you think you are you're a 39 grown your
old man make the right decision and not
be creep and he refers themselves like
sometimes i feel like a creepy said i i
almost felt like a creep when she said
do you want to play minecraft so he's
already thinking is she too young for me
because she plays minecraft if you think
she's too young for you she's too young
for you bro you have grown ass man
watching
anime
that's a young [ __ ]
it's cartoons i mean no no no not
because you just you you watch it you
watch it it's not no it could no if i
japanese culture anime is not i'll just
be honest with you i understand what
you're saying okay but if in my mind i
think it is
there's grown-ass people that play
minecraft
she thinks
it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter there's people that do
things that are there's a bunch of
there's a bunch of adults that have a
bunch of action figures
you're right it doesn't matter if you
think it's it's you should get oh that's
kids it doesn't matter
but kim will attack and i'm ready for
he's gonna attack me face but whatever
they're all gonna attack me because of
like oh well nutritious past like she
did this this and this or whatever like
that but i'm not ruining someone's knife
i'm not manipulating someone way younger
than me
in ruining their lives for a quick for a
quick fix a quick pleasure pump whatever
you want to call it yeah when you were
[ __ ] up other people's lives or
creating drama for them you were doing
it for noble causes you're such a
wonderful person
okay and faith tries to rationalize it
well like with like well if it's if it's
consensual
i'm sorry the legal age should be 25 i
know it's
totally different things but they're
they're also kind of like the same thing
it's like you should know better as a
but if they're over 35 and you're under
the age of 21
25 whatever
there's something seriously wrong with
these people with with the older person
pursuing the younger there's something
seriously wrong with them seriously
disturbed with them that they can't get
someone their agent they don't want to
get someone their age because they're so
psychologically messed up they're so
stupid they're so there's something so
all you [ __ ] were on george clooney's
ass i didn't hear all you
on george rooney's ass nick carter brad
pitt all them old [ __ ] antonio
cebato jr but now 2021 you're brand new
shut the [ __ ] up about your dumb [ __ ]
you were on damn old nigga's asses and
then now it's not good no more maybe
shut up
i don't care she's 20 i don't give a
[ __ ]
she's saying a thing trying to make a
thing out of something that is not a
thing this is not a thing this is not a
problem can you man you're a magician
you're making drama out of thin air it's
not a thing
the girl's not complaining about it the
guy's not complaining about it they're
cool with it that's it but now they're
trying to create this whole victim
scenario where the girl might look at it
and she might get gasoline into thinking
something happened when it did it
it's a weird world my friends she's
she just said guys i want you to peek
this she just said the age of consent
should be 25
25 25. she said you're not an adult
responsible enough to make decisions for
yourself until you're 25. this is how i
already knew this was going this way
when the call me carson thing happened
in 19 and 17 year old got together
everybody lost their minds i'm making
[ __ ] losers what are you they're two
years apart even keemstar himself who's
now with a 20 year old he said some dumb
[ __ ] about that which i think is
hilarious
this is the slippery slope that i was
telling you guys about i knew this was
coming
they're gonna find some dumb
justification you guys there's so many
reasons why dudes go for younger women
whether it's virility being able to have
kids or whether they just came out of a
divorce and they just want some hot
piece of ass because the youngest girls
look better it is what it is keep it
pushing it's not for you you don't think
cougars get out of marriages and then
want to go for young dudes because
they're strong there's not something
wrong with them they want a good sex
life because [ __ ] their age are
traditionally lazy and they're not
checking for them it's not rocket
science but i feel like people don't
want to understand it they live in this
delusional idealistic world of what it's
supposed to be like it's because they're
so psychologically messed up they're so
stupid they're so there's something so
deeply disturbed misogynist or whatever
the case is with this person that they
can't find someone somewhat compatible
within their adrian during like the
10-year age range the 10-year rate how
is that so 10 years arbitrary that's
good that's good who who made that up
she did who made that up and she's going
to judge you if you don't follow her
random guy the [ __ ] out of here three
and i'm dating a 63 i'm 33. i've lived
my life my brain is fully developed not
the way you speak
and i thought but i but i liked it i
enjoyed it
you can like it and enjoy it and be
happy and it's still wrong it's still
messed up just because you suffer again
this is one of those things where
because it happened to me it's gonna
happen to you
i got into a car and i got in a car
accident so you're gonna get into a car
you're gonna get a car accident this is
a dumb [ __ ] though we don't we're at the
end we're at the end look let's listen
guys i was mad then
when they did it to the random dude
carson and i think it's stupid now and i
think it's going to continue being
stupid going forward we are essentially
infantilizing adults especially women
we're seeing women are these weak little
meek things that need to be protected
even past the age of 18 at the age of 25
and you know what they're going to move
the goal post again they're going to
always find ways to move the goal post
so this is what i'm going to say
this is what i'm going to say here's
what i'm saying if you want to be an uh
an adult understand the responsibilities
that comes with the choices that you
make okay and there's no guarantee like
listen women are dating [ __ ] their own
age and still getting heartbroken and
picked up and manipulated it has nothing
to do with like this age gap is there
more propensity for this person to have
more power sure but guess what most like
power people like people that can do
things for them if a girl wants to get
with a man who can get her nice things
and take her to nice restaurants who are
you to stop her and say you don't have
the agency we are infantilizing adults
and it's just a reflection of our
inability to accept accountability for
the choices that we're making so that's
where i'm gonna stop it there and the
last thing i must say i find it funny
that women by all scientific measures
mature faster than men both mentally and
physically and yet when a 19 year old
male gets with a 17 year old woman you
guys think there's some great imbalance
and they're not ready for each other
maturely maturity speech i was about to
say that i was about to leave on that
but barry
last thing i was i'm gonna say before i
get the [ __ ] out of here if i was a
woman listening to that i'd be [ __ ]
pissed
because that's insulting to you
[ __ ] that's it it is
it is you're calling you're you're
stepping on here calling us all type of
all bunch of type of misogynistic that's
misogynistic
that's that's just belittling you
don't go after us go after them
[Music]
foreign